the day-to-day routine of Dr gears
consisted of a few constants piping hot
cups of black unsweetened coffee plain
dry wheat toast the soothing sounds of
his favorite white noise machine and the
endless Carousel of experiments with
scp-914 not that he was complaining he
was perfectly content to spend his time
supervising one of the few anomalies he
crossed paths with on a regular basis
that was unlikely to kill or maim him in
any way not that the Clockworks hadn't
produced its fair share of unpredictable
results over the years of extensive
testing it had definitely offered up
more than a few surprises and anyone who
knew Dr gears knew that he was not
especially fond of surprises Dr bright
had attempted to throw a surprise
birthday party for the man once but when
he turned on the lights and fired the
confetti cannon all Dr gears did in
response was give a deep sigh and say
really Jack you're making a spectacle of
yourself still he had designed himself
long ago to the fact that supervising
the experiments with scp-914 meant
witnessing some truly unpredictable
outcomes how could he forget the time
researcher Blass tested an incandescent
light bulb on the setting very fine and
the Machine spat out an anthropomorphic
humanoid light bulb that spoke in German
accented English and claimed to be
Thomas Edison himself this was of course
impossible as historical records surely
would have indicated if Thomas Edison
was a walking talking light bulb rather
than a human man the Imposter was
eventually incinerated after its
presence became too irritating to ignore
and then there was the time researcher
Thompson filled out a Dungeons and
Dragons character sheet and placed it
into the machine on the setting very
fine the output produced was a sheet of
paper promoting the previously
non-existent tabletop role-playing game
fear in the foundation whenever a person
read the paper they would suddenly find
themselves in an out of Body Experience
where they were inside the game's World
which which contains several characters
related to the SCP Foundation as well as
items and locations based on real-world
counterparts a subject in this state
would only snap back to reality after
winning or dying in the game researcher
Jacobson were all the one on stealth and
saw
scp-096's face in the game and was later
found dead in the anomalous item storage
Wing there was no shortage of foundation
staff trying to use the machine for
personal gain too Dr naysmith placed his
credit card inside on the setting very
fine using it to produce a card covered
in unidentified corporate insignias and
reading rank aleph infinite money
privileges when Dr Coltrane issued a
written warning Dr Naismith took that
warning and then placed it into the
machine on the same setting producing a
piece of official documentation from the
o5 council in support of his infinite
money privileges Junior researcher
Summers attempted to use scp-914 in a
misguided attempt at self-improvement
placing not an object but herself in the
intake Booth before running the machine
on the setting very fine it cleared her
skin lengthened her hair and improved
her figure this was of course in
violation of several employee guidelines
and she was promptly dismissed after
emerging from scp-914 Dr Veritas left a
note in the experiment log following
this incident reading by the time we
realized what she was actually doing it
was too late to stop her needless to say
she's since been terminated and I hope I
don't need to tell you all not to do
that again and with that the guideline
was clear no one was permitted to use
scp-914 for personal gain or to change
anything about themselves potential
complications were too risky not to
mention the conflicts of interest that
would be introduced into what should be
an impartial research process as
scientific objectivity's biggest fan Dr
gears couldn't agree more so as he
settled in for the day's round of tests
he intended to keep a watchful things
ensure that no funny business would take
place he didn't have much reason for
concern as his colleague Dr Bonita
prepped her research materials she was
working with two items a small replica
of Michelangelo's sculpture of David a
distilled envelope containing something
that was to be handled with Extreme
Caution a photograph of
scp-096's face she planned to place the
items inside on the very fine setting in
an attempt to see what result might be
produced from combining an ideal of
traditional beauty standards with the
image of a creature that felt such
profound shame and distress as its own
appearance that it would destroy anyone
who looked at its face like any good
scientist Dr Bonita wanted to remove any
unnecessary variables from her
experiment so as she placed her items
inside the intake Booth she slowly
delicately unsealed the
she wanted to put the picture inside by
itself without the extra element of the
envelope potentially complicating things
unfortunately like Marie curie's slowly
unintentionally poisoning herself with
her own research materials she didn't
truly understand the danger of what she
held in her hands just as she was
setting the photograph down her eyes
flickered to the image before she could
stop herself before she could even look
away or squeeze her eyes shut she caught
a glimpse of the one thing she should
never look at
scp-096's face she gasped and slammed
the photograph down but she knew it was
too late the sound of an inhuman shriek
coming from across the facility signaled
that she
it was coming for her and nothing in the
world could stop in a containment cell
on the other side of the facility
Foundation staff were horrified as they
heard The Telltale scream of an enraged
scp-096 the pale Finn creature once
huddled in the corner silently had
stretched to its full height of 2.38
meters and was screaming sobbing wailing
and gibberish and beginning to tear its
way out of its chamber guards tried
their best to subdue The Entity firing
their weapons at it but the bullets did
nothing to damage the creature's pale
flesh or stop its movements it ripped
through the steel Cube that contained it
and knocked the guards out of its way
with one
actually long arms sending them for
weaning into a nearby wall fortunately
for them scp-096 only knocked them
unconscious it didn't stop to harm them
further as it had a more important goal
in line find the person who had seen its
face and Destroy them as the alarm
blared signifying a high Threat Level
containment range
scp-096 Lopes down the hall toward Dr
Bonita in s
Dr gears had not spotted Dr Bonita's
grave mistake and had no idea what had
triggered the alarm he was hearing he
stepped away from the observation window
turning his attention to the crisis that
was clearly happening somewhere else in
the facility meanwhile Dr Bonita was
panicking she saw her life flash before
her eyes the certainty of impending doom
that was coming for her and coming fast
all because of one brief error in
judgment what could she do there was
nowhere to hide no way she could run
away fast enough unless if she managed
to Allure 096 into the intake booth and
start the machine while the creature was
inside maybe it would transform into
something less intent on tearing her
limb from limb it was a risky move and
one that could jeopardize her position
at the foundation but she couldn't very
well keep her job if she was dead so it
seemed like it just might be worth a
shot a primal Roar of Agony Fury
interrupted her thoughts and she knew
that scp-096 was moments away from
breaking down the door and getting its
hands on her she would have to move fast
with a screeching grind of metal on
metal
scp-096 wrenched the door off its hinges
and barreled into the room in its search
for the person who had seen its face it
ran toward the silhouette of Dr Bonita
standing just at the entrance to the
intake Booth she tucked and rolled out
of the way just as the monster entered
the
the door automatically slides shut
behind it it is scp-096 rattled the door
and tried to free itself she turned the
knob to very fine with every ounce of
strength and speed she had there was a
ding of a small Bell in the machine word
to life as the objects inside were
refined Dr Bonita had no idea what would
be waiting for her in the output Booth
but she could only hope that her
last-ditch effort had managed to save
her life in the fog of panic she briefly
felt an itch of scientific curiosity too
what would become of a being like
scp-096 in a machine as strange and
wonderful as scp-914 what would the
addition of the statue do to it as a
door to the outtake Booth slid open
Steam poured out it appeared her
questions would soon be answered
cautiously in spite of herself Dr Bonita
called out hello no one answered but she
heard the sound of footsteps slow and
careful as a figure emerged from the
Mist she covered her mouth and sharp her
eyes wide dear God she whispered and awe
standing in front of her with pale
smooth skin and the same imposing
stature was the most beautiful man she
had ever seen why dark shown under thick
sculpted eyebrows under the eyes an
aqualine nose full pouty lips a strong
sharp jawline his head was topped with a
tangle of lustrous dark curls it was the
kind of hair she had only seen flowing
in the Wind on the covers of the romance
novels she wanted desperately to buy but
was too embarrassed to be seen
purchasing his physique was well
statuesque like the build of the very
Michelangelo sculpture she had placed
into the machine just moments ago there
was no other way to say it he was
handsome despite still being a little
lanky and nine feet tall he peered at
her curiously towering over her in a way
that had been terrifying in his former
shape but now made her heart skip a beat
in an entirely different way hi was all
she could think to say was she blushing
she shook her head snapping herself out
of it she was a scientist damn it not
some giddy school girl passing notes in
class this was incredible achievement
something she would need to study
thoroughly and she very much wanted to
study him thoroughly nope no time for
that she needed to write up a report to
inform her superiors to try her best not
to lose her job over this she had to
remain professional I the man that had
once been or perhaps still was as cp096
spoke oh you you can talk Dr Bonita
laughed in Surprise the man's brow
furrowed his Newfound ability to speak
was a surprise to him too it seemed yes
I can what happened to me yeah stumbling
over his words slightly getting used to
the feeling of them you ran into the
machine she gestured to scp-914 I'm not
exactly sure to be honest but you're
very different now he nodded I feel
different I feel calm he sighed the
relief plane on his face before shadow
of sadness fell over him I don't think I
have to hurt anyone I I'm sorry for what
I did before Dr Bonita did not know what
to say how do you respond when something
you've been studying from afar been
horrified and fascinated by an equal
measure looks at you with a new
beautiful face and apologizes for all
the harm it caused this whole experience
was so surreal that she might think she
was dreaming if she didn't work at a
place that was one long waking dream or
nightmare depending on the day Dr Bonita
there's been a Containment Breach are
you all right Dr gears had returned to
the room taking in the sight of the
destruction left in 096's way I'm fine
she called to him and he followed her
voice into the room then stopped at the
site of the transformed anomaly I don't
have time for whatever this is I trust
you'll handle it Dr took a long sip of
his coffee and taking Bonita's shock
silence as confirmation had a leisurely
stroll back to his office a few moments
later the guards responsible for
containing scp-096 arrived on the scene
expecting to see Carnage and find a
docile scp-096 crouched over a lifeless
body but instead they found the same
truly bizarre site that Dr gears had
Shrugged off and Dr Bonita was still
doing her best to process they entered
the room with their weapons drawn but
quickly lowered them scratching their
heads in confusion instead before
radioing their superiors and asking for
further instructions responses from
various Foundation staff who caught a
glimpse of scp-096's bold noon look
included oh would you look at that who's
that guy he's what and in the words of
Dr Jack Bright oh no he's hot
Dr bright also proposed making the new
scp-096 a tick tock account and YouTube
channel seeking modeling representation
for him or selling a novelty calendar
filled with pictures of 096 in various
costumes these would be in his words
quote excellent ways to increase revenue
for the foundation so really you're the
weird ones now for thinking my ideas are
weird Dr Wright was asked to leave
scp-096 alone and stop trying to take
his headshot in the days that followed
the incident with scp-914 the SCP
Foundation was at a loss about what to
do with this new seemingly harmless
version of scp-096 dozens of d-class
were brought in to look at his face and
see if the entity would still enter one
of his range States after a few days of
getting used to his new form but he
never did no screaming no swallowing
people whole nothing more than a polite
is somewhat shy greeting and a courteous
how are you doing today the d-classes
were relieved but confused about being
pulled from their cells just to stare at
some random handsome man Dr clef
suggested dissecting scp-096 to see what
his new body looked like on the inside
this request was denied several
interviews were conducted to evaluate
scp-096's mental and emotional state now
that the anomaly was capable of coherent
speech it was much simpler to evaluate
the Potential Threat Level he might pose
every researcher who spoke with him came
to the same conclusion gone was the
danger of the old
scp-096 he had not just become beautiful
in a classical superficial sense but he
had become beautiful on the inside as
well interviewers reported a warm
friendly demeanor a talent for engaging
in conversation once he was made to feel
comfortable and a sincere interest in
the thoughts opinions and feelings of
those he spoke with there was only one
thing left to do to make sure that
scp-096 had really changed from
something deadly to something almost
resembling an ordinary person a
photograph of
scp-096's face of its original face was
removed from a Secure Vault by a d-class
then the d-class was sent into a room
with scp-096 and instructed to place the
photograph on the table
scp-096 looked down at what had once
been his face and his eyes felled with
tears a soft broken saw left his lips
and he wrapped his arms around himself
hunching over as if in physical pain
outside the room guards prepared to
handle things if 096 began to attack
instead he wiped his tears took a deep
shuddering breath and looked at the
d-class with a somber expression he
picked up the photograph on the table
and tore it in half as he finally
summoned the strength to speak please
get rid of these that is not who I am
anymore at Dr Bonita's strong insistence
backed up by the conclusions of the
research staff who interviewed scp-096 a
reevaluation of the entity's containment
measure was ordered it seemed cruel and
unnecessary waste of resources to keep
096 trapped in a steel cube in its
current form he would be moved to a
standard humanoid containment cell and
treat it as well as other safe class
anomalies provided with books films food
and drink upon request and of course
other Comforts of course the o5 council
insisted on evaluating The Entity before
any of these changes could be approved
dressed in a specially tailored suit
provided by Dr Bonita
scp-096 appeared before the council to
present his case I know that I might not
have the best record at the foundation
I've done a lot of damage over the years
though let's be honest you all aren't
exactly innocent either sorry that was
an attempt at a joke I'm still very new
to talking all I can say is please
consider giving me another chance to
make a real life here to make this place
my home thank you for your time but
scp-096 didn't know is that the o5
council was so flabbergasted by the side
of his new face that they didn't retain
a single word he said they had all given
their official approval before he even
finished his short presentation before
long scp-096 was moved out of his steel
Cube and into a new containment chamber
that resembled a mid-range studio
apartment complete with a bed a
kitchenette a television and a table and
chairs he was provided access to all
major streaming platforms as well as a
large stack of books to help him develop
his grasp of culture and language after
so very long being isolated from Human
Society though he wasn't exactly human
he was determined to act like it word
quickly spread around the foundation
site and humans and anomalies alike
flock to scp-096's new home to visit him
and see miraculous transformation for
themselves as CP 999 was the first to
come and see the new and improved 096
chirping excitedly as it oozed into his
room he Pat the Slime gently his face
breaking into a warm Smile as its
euphoric effect washed over him the
Slime became so excited that meeting
this new friend someone it had known as
a source of sadness and hurt for so long
that it tackled him to the ground and
tickled him for several minutes 096
laughing uproariously all the while
scp-343 stopped by to give 096 his
Blessing and wish him well in this new
chapter of Life a few days later scp-507
popped back into the site and wanted to
see the changes for himself he was
thoroughly impressed though privately
confessed to missing 096's more
monstrous form which reminded him of
some of his favorite Cryptids there was
one anomaly that was not thrilled with
the appearance of scp-096 however
scp-056 was Furious upon hearing about
the new beautiful man that everyone just
couldn't shut up about it demanded a
chance to speak to scp-096 and to tell
him that this place isn't big enough for
the both of us I'm the fairest one of
all you sniveling little worm but the
request was denied
scp-056 salt about it for several weeks
meanwhile Dr Bonita was still intent on
getting to know
scp-096 better during previous testing
with scp-978 the desire camera a photo
taken of scp-096 revealed that his
greatest desire was to disappear curious
about the results would be now Dr Bonita
received permission to take another
picture of scp-096 she snapped the photo
while 096 was sitting in a chair in his
new containment chamber looking directly
at the camera when the photo developed
the result was simple everything in the
picture was exactly the same with one
exception Dr Bonito was pictured sitting
next to zero nine six her hand clasped
in his both were smiling soft contented
smiles when she showed him the
photograph he smiled at her and shook
his head it really is an amazing camera
she flushed doctor before you go could I
ask her name Dr Bonita smiled and nodded
it's Isabel what should I call you
scp-096 paused thoughtfully for a moment
he was giving himself a name for the
very first time allowing himself an
identity other than a strange Hollow
pale thing that existed to cry and
suffer and hurt finally he answered her
call me David now go check out the whole
story what if scp-096 wore scp-035 and
scp-049 cures as cp096 of the pestilence
for more bizarre what-ifs about scp-096